so far with the vast majority of the
shapes that I have talked to you about I
have taken that 3d shape and I've said
will you understand the surface area by
thinking about its knit right however 3d
shapes are tricky like you remember I
asked you about count the number of
faces on this shape yesterday right
sometimes that's hard because you can't
see what's going on on a flat piece of
paper like these in your textbook or
your workbook etc so for that reason for
almost all the shapes I have presented
to you I've created just a 3d model how
to paper and today is no exception
so I came here this code is actually
really special we're going to develop
the surface area of this card because of
the fact that it is is round I suppose
you could kind of call it a circular
pyramid because of that the formula for
the second area is kind of weird we're
going to develop it but it's gonna be so
much easier if you just look at my cone
but you have one of your own so if you
have a pair of scissors what we're
looking at here is just the cone right
we get to squeeze later on just like
every other surface area we looked at
you can take the 3d shape unfolded which
gives you the net and then look at each
of the components now you remember when
I gave you this to begin with
it looks like this okay
so just in case yours has been tortured
beyond recognition okay you had the
circles these extra bits aren't part of
the surface area what is that yeah
that's right it's just there so you've
got something to stick on to so they're
a really form part of the cone but
you've got this bit down here now does
anyone know what this shape is actually
called it starts with an S so this is
the circle which starts with a c then
this thing is actually called a sector
and we all need to write this down
so you got a second is it ring about and
then you've got a sec done now to work
out the surface area of this cone just
like every other area we need two
measurements the first one's the most
obvious one you did the area of a circle
in our review this morning the area mr.
Doyley requires a single measurement for
its area namely the radius right the
radius so I'm just so quite likely to
add that radius in I'd also like you to
put it in on the cone it's really
important that you can sort of map back
and forth between this 2d representation
and what's happening in three dimensions
so this radius and this radius seem like
now from there the quickest way the most
efficient way to get the remaining area
is to work out something called the
slant height now do you remember we've
triangles that we looked at right angle
triangle before the perpendicular height
is standing upright like this I can look
at it already on purpose but it's up
there straight up and down and it would
be in a right angle with the radius the
slant height as its name suggests is
slanted okay so where we gonna put it in
this on this diagram is here okay now
we're not gonna call it a tree because
that's confusing we use 8 for the real
height the perpendicular height so to
distinguish this one I'm going to just
call it L for length but it's the slant
height and I'm going to name it that so
that I remember
what's talking about all right now let's
start to have a look over onto this 2d
pup area of the circle we know that
really well the area of a circle is just
PI us web so we know that really really
well now the area sector is a little bit
trickier there's different ways to work
out what the area of a sector is
depending on what information you have
access to so being that for us we have
this radius down here
and this slant height here's how we're
going to work it out I want you to look
at your home in front of you okay why
won't you see where is the slant height
on your curve if you've done it well I
think you'll find the same height is
actually marked in for you do you see it
there see that that seam along there
that's the slant hi are you following
with me so look at that slant height now
go back rewind in time where is that
line on here where is it
hmm now it is a radius the radius of
what firm no it's the radius the sector
it's it's this thing here do you see
that in fact that's the physical line in
fact if you colored it you might have
noticed this line becomes and that line
there that slant home okay so therefore
I can take the elements over here and I
can bring it over to this part over here
okay now you've got to be a little
careful with yourself here because even
though these may look like circles that
are roughly the same size the circles
that these come from are not the same
size have a look at this sector
do you see if I completed it we fit that
sector that circle would be much bigger
than this guy which makes the what it is
turn into it turn into the base
cinematic a so there are actually
different sizes that means there are
different radii radiuses be careful with
that all right
I've got this knife over here think
carefully with me I want you to have a
look at this sector and the round part
that goes all the way around okay now we
can actually work out that round part
there it's called an arc
and I'm going to show you how okay but
you need to think very carefully you
remember when you cut both things out
and then you I folded this around so it
was the round bit the kurta and then you
fit it onto here do you remember that
now wonder if you remember look at your
shape carefully wait folded this around
see this arc here I'm talking about did
you notice that I deliberately planned
this net so that this arc exactly sat on
top of the base did you notice that
right it wasn't bigger than the base it
wasn't smaller it lined up really nicely
and that's how you can make an actual
coat so what is this length all the way
around it's that it's the circumference
of which circle because there's two it's
the base circle right now I know what
the radius is so what is this
circumference it's just going to play
off so this art is the same way so it's
too high okay we've got all the pieces
in place now we need to do a little bit
of work with equations